mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
the sum of x y and z is one
the sum of their squares is two and the
sum of their cubes is three
what is the sum of their fifth powers
i thank daniel in england for suggesting
this problem
it was shared on social media with such
claims like solve if you are a genius
and 99
can't solve this
these titles turn some people off
but mind your decisions has been a
pioneer in solving such problems in
spite of some unfair criticism these
videos have received huge praise because
they share mathematical topics with
people who otherwise never would have
studied it
consider this very problem
the variation of the sum of the fourth
powers is asked in a university math
textbook abstract algebra by dummit and
foot
these problems actually relate to higher
level mathematics
you could solve the sum of the fourth
powers and the sum of the fifth powers
using high school algebra and clever
tricks
it's not easy but it is possible
in this video i'm going to show you a
systematic approach to solving these
problems and it will involve a little
bit of build up because we're going to
study some university level mathematical
topics but i think it will be worth it
pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these problems
we'll get started with the numerical
approach if we input these equations
into wolfram alpha we'll get approximate
values for x y and z
we can substitute that in to get an
approximate value for the sum of the
fifth powers
it appears to be a complex number
but we might just take a guess that this
is a real number and it's equal to six
in fact this is the actual answer which
we'll prove later in the video
but there's something interesting when
you take a numerical approach
you get more than one solution set of x
y and z
you actually get six different solution
sets by permuting the values for x y and
z
in total there will be three factorial
which equals six solution sets
the reason for the symmetry is we're
dealing with symmetric polynomials
a symmetric polynomial is one in which
it's unchanged for any permutation of
the variable subscripts
if we exchange one and two we would have
to get exactly the same polynomial
if we do a more complicated permutation
we would also have to get exactly the
same polynomial
in general this polynomial has to be the
same for any permutation sigma of the
variable subscripts
so let's take a look at a concrete
example
consider the polynomial x1 plus x2
it's unchanged for the identity
permutation which does nothing
and it's also unchanged for the other
permutation that transposes 1 and 2.
these two polynomials are always equal
to each other and therefore x1 plus x2
is a symmetric polynomial
on the other hand x1 minus x2 is not
symmetric
while it's unchanged for the identity
permutation
it is changed if we transpose one and
two in general x1 minus x2 is not equal
to x2 minus x1
this is not a symmetric polynomial
but we can modify this to get a
symmetric polynomial imagine we square
the polynomial
this will be a symmetric polynomial
i'll mention what we're doing is an
example of group theory which is the
study of such symmetries i briefly
introduced group theory in my video
multiplied by lines group theory
i showed that you could take the tall
walker square diagram for an arithmetic
problem and then exploit the symmetries
of the square to solve new arithmetic
problems
so how does that relate to our original
problem
well these are a system of power sum
symmetric polynomials or power sum
polynomials for short
each of these is a different powersum
polynomial and the degree refers to the
exponent of the variables
let me just put this in a little bit
more formal notation the kth degree
powersum polynomial for n variables will
be the sum of the variables to the kth
power
so we'll translate our equations into
power sum polynomial notation
we want to solve for p5
now since we know we're dealing with
three variables we'll just abbreviate
this by removing the x y and z
so how can we solve for the value p5
to do that we'll need to study the
elementary symmetric polynomials
these are the building blocks for all
symmetric polynomials
so let me just show you the formal
definition and then i'll give you some
intuition
e k will be the sum of all terms where
each term is the product of taking k
variables at a time and if we have more
than n
so e of r for r greater than n it'll be
equal to zero
in our problem we have three variables x
y and z
these are the elementary symmetric
polynomials
since we're dealing with x y and z i'll
just abbreviate this
and now we're going to take these
elementary symmetric polynomials and
relate it to the power sums
to do that we'll start all over
consider a polynomial of degree n as
follows it'll be in the variable t
this will have n roots over the complex
numbers and we'll label them as x1 to xn
some of the roots may be equal to each
other but that doesn't matter it will
have a total of n roots
therefore we can factor the polynomial
as follows it'll be the product of these
linear terms
we can now compare these two versions of
the polynomial
so what happens when we expand this
polynomial well the leading term will be
t to the power of n we then have
negative e1 multiplied by t to the power
of n minus one the coefficient on the
second term will be negative the sum of
the roots and that's something you might
have learned in school but this is where
it comes from now the next term will
also have a coefficient that's an
elementary symmetric polynomial and this
will actually continue in an alternating
sum
now what can we do here we'll make some
substitutions
suppose we have f of x one
well in the first equation we know that
this factor will cancel out to be zero
because x one is a root therefore we
know this is equal to zero but we can
substitute it into our second equation
and we'll get the following expression
we can do this for all of the n roots on
the one hand it'll be equal to zero and
on the other hand we'll get an
expression
so when we do that we get a system of n
equations
and we can do something interesting we
can sum these equations together
the left hand side will be equal to zero
now what happens on the right hand side
well some column by column
the first column will be the sum of
these n variables to the nth power
in other words this is p n it's a power
sum polynomial as the leading term
this pattern will continue for the rest
of these sums we're going to get power
sum
polynomials all the way until the very
end where we get n
times negative 1 to the power of n e n
now this formula right here is
interesting
it relates the elementary symmetric
polynomials to the other polynomials and
the power sums
now technically we derived this for e n
in n variables but this formula actually
doesn't depend on the number of
variables and i'm going to present it in
another way which will be useful to
solve our problem
so these are often called the newton
identities but they were discovered in
1629 by albert gerar and then it was
later discovered by newton in 1666
some people call them the newton-jarrar
identities but at mind your decisions we
respect mathematical history and believe
it would be more correct to call them
the girar newton identities so here are
the identities k multiplied by e k is
equal to e k minus 1 multiplied by p 1
minus e k minus 2 multiplied by p 2
plus so on in an alternating sum all the
way to negative 1 raised to the power of
k minus 1 e zero multiplied by p k
this is what the formula looks like in
sigma notation so here are some tricks
to remember this formula
it starts out with e k minus one
multiplied by p one this will always be
true
we then have an alternating sum
and finally each term will have the
following form the elementary symmetric
polynomials will decrease while the
power sum polynomials will increase and
the sum of the indices will always be
equal to k in each of these terms and
that goes all the way to the very end
so we'll use these identities to solve
our problem
to recall these are the elementary
symmetric polynomials related to x y and
z
and these are the power sum polynomials
that we were given and the values of
them
so we'll get started that p1 equals 1
and that's exactly e1 therefore e1 is
equal to 1.
now let's solve for e2
2 multiplied by e2
equals e1 p1 minus e0 p2
we have the values for all of these
except e2
so we'll substitute in and simplify and
we can solve that e2 is equal to
negative 0.5
we now will solve for e3
3 multiplied by e3 will be equal to e2
p1
minus e1 p2 plus e0 p3
we substitute in the values we've
derived
and the only thing that remains will be
3 times e3 will be equal to 0.5
therefore e3 equals 1 over 6.
now consider 4 times e4
this will be equal to e3 p1 minus e2 p2
plus e1 p3 minus e0 p4
what is e4
well
4 is greater than 3 so the elementary
symmetric polynomial will be equal to 0.
this term will vanish
we then substitute in values for things
we've already derived
the only unknown in this equation is p4
and we have a linear equation which we
can solve for p4
it equals 25 over 6. and recall p4 is
the power sum polynomial the sum of the
fourth powers so this is one part of the
problem we've already solved just by
going through this formula
now
let's look at five times e5
it'll be the following expression
and e of 5 and e of 4 will be equal to 0
because 5 and 4 are greater than 3
so these terms will vanish
we then substitute in values we've
derived and the only unknown is p5
we'll solve for p5 and we get the value
of 6.
and that's the answer to our problem
this is the sum of the fifth powers and
we've derived it using the other
elementary symmetric polynomials and the
other power sums
this is incredible
now i have a challenge for you
try to solve for the sum of the sixth
powers
furthermore
prove that the sum of the nth powers is
rational for every positive integer n
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you